I got taken to the middle of the mob
to stand on a Bandstand and when I got
there I just I had no idea the police
weren't there I just assumed because
they said they cooperate I mean they
said it they they wanted to know where I
was before I got in the country and so I
assumed that meant they were going to
protect me and they took it really
seriously because I'd been escorted in a
couple of airports by Australian police
but instead when I got there I was
searched for two hours and interrogated
my hotel had already canceled and then
when I got to the hotel when I woke up
the next day I had a threatening letter
under my door so I probably shouldn't
have been surprised and I felt it right
I'm not particularly a spiritual person
or believe in those sorts of things but
I felt it in my bones I was very afraid
actually going to the event